doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is full of narrative twists and
turns but there are a few story threads
left unexplained keep watching because
these are the biggest plot holes from dr
strange 2 that need some explaining
the film opens with a sequence in which
an alternate doctor strange known as
defender strange fails to protect
america chavez as she attempts to grab
the book of vashanti dr strange of earth
616 then wakes up in a cold sweat from
what appears to be a bad dream very
early on in the film once america
appears in his reality strange comes to
understand that his nightmares aren't
his guilty subconscious but glimpses
into other realities in other universes
everything he saw in his dream did
happen which america proves when she
drags defender strange's corpse out of a
rooftop garden check the idea that
dreams could potentially link divergent
realities is interesting and has
potential but that potential is
completely unexplored in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness no
explanation is given and seemingly
contradictory evidence exists in other
mcu properties for example wanda
manipulates dreams in avengers age of
ultron what characters see has to do
with their deepest fears and possible
futures in their own reality one could
argue that these were visions and not
true dreams but it strains credibility
that every dream from the banal to the
most extreme in every universe is a
window into another world in the finale
of one division wanda comes to terms
with what she's done and puts westview
mostly back to how it was and just for
good measure she traps agatha harkness
into domestic life as agnes then she
envisioned tuck their kids into bed one
last time knowing that everyone but
wanda will disappear once the hex wears
off but in an end credits scene wanda's
physical form is seeking solace by the
lake while her astral forum studies the
darkhold in the very last moment of the
series she hears her boys screaming out
for help that scene makes it seem as
though wanda's tommy and billy didn't
just cease to exist with the hex but are
out there somewhere in the multiverse
many fans assumed the plot of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
would revolve around her traveling from
universe to universe searching for their
specific variants instead the scarlet
witch is content to have her children in
any reality she can find them in does
this mean they're biologically her kids
in other universes or she's still
operating hexes throughout multiple
realities and what happened to the twins
from the hex if she could still hear
them the boy's status at the end of one
division is never meaningfully revisited
as one division drew to a close the
mystery as to what had become of the
real vision was solved the vision who
lived with wanda and the hex was her
creation the one whose corpse was kept
at sword headquarters was ultimately
reanimated with traces of wanda's chaos
magic and reprogrammed to destroy wanda
and the projection of vision he nearly
succeeded until his double stumped him
at which point white vision essentially
downloaded his foes memories and
disappeared
[Music]
many fans anticipated that white vision
would return in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness perhaps to stop
wanda from doing something terrible not
only is there no white vision in the
film but there's no vision at all wanda
and her boys live in domestic bliss in
an infinite number of realities but
vision doesn't appear to exist in any of
them what happened to all the visions
how did all those wandas end up with all
those kids the lack of visions is
particularly odd in light of the
illuminati's defeat of thanos in their
own universe it involved the darkhold
and the book of ashanti not vision
sacrifice it's possible that vision
never existed on earth 838 as ultron
bots appear to serve the illuminati here
but it seems unlikely that vision would
have come to be only on earth 616 and it
seems like an oversight that white
vision doesn't return to deal with wanda
the whole premise of one division is
that following the events of avengers
infinity war wanda was so traumatized by
the death of her synthetic soulmate that
she mind controlled an entire town just
so she could imagine having him back in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness she is instead single-mindedly
focused on getting back to her children
and she seems to have completely given
up hope of ever being with viz again
wanda confides to strange that vision
believed the multiverse was real and had
theories about it this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous wanda
claims she's being reasonable as she
causes mayhem in the first half of the
movie because of her motherly love if
she knew about the multiverse especially
once she had her hands on the darkhold
it seems much more reasonable that she'd
want to find a reality in which she got
to be with her husband and her kids but
as we've established that there are no
visions to be found out there even in
infinite universes maybe she knows
something that we don't wanda is also
aware of the white vision in her own
universe even though he's gone missing
as overpowered with magic as she's
become it defies logic that she wouldn't
at least try to bring him under her
spell wanda's sharp pivot from caring
only about vision to caring only about
her kids makes for thin plotting and
character development
when america chavez and doctor strange
accidentally traveled to another reality
they learned that this one is wise to
the multiverse it has designated itself
earth 838 and strange's reality
earth-616
this is a plot complication both within
the marvel cinematic universe and
between marvel comics and marvel studios
but that creates an inconsistency
between what marvel studios calls the
mcu's prime reality and what earth838
calls it as well as differences between
what happens in the movies versus the
comics until now it was widely accepted
that marvel comics largely took place in
a reality known as earth 616
while the marvel movies and tv shows
took place in one often known as earth
199999
though there's an increasing amount of
overlap between comics and mcu
storylines the narratives and characters
on the page and screen are still very
much distinct from each other
america chavez is introduced to
audiences as a young and reluctant
superpower wielder who can't yet control
her multiverse jumping abilities she
also shows the potential for super
strength and speed in her fights against
gargantos and scarlet witch but where
did she learn to harness any of her
powers peter parker had mentors like
tony stark and steven strange to guide
his development other characters even
strange received some backstory and
on-screen instruction from their mentors
and audiences received some explanation
from the script we have no idea how
america got her power was she born like
thor or forged like wanda then she's
suddenly able to harness her power at
will simply because doctor strange
believed in her and told her to believe
in herself that's a pretty weak allusion
to the concept of controlling one's fear
we see that america first teleported
when she was stung by a bee and every
unintentional multiversal trip since has
been related to america feeling afraid
considering the shorter than usual run
time of multiverse of madness the newest
mcu character skill set could have been
better illustrated
wand vision and loki both contain easter
eggs and references to nexus beings and
it's heavily implied that wanda is one a
one division faux commercial contains
the tagline nexus
because the world doesn't revolve around
you
or does it the exact definition of a
nexus being is malleable even in the
comics and is barely even established in
the mcu but generally these exceedingly
rare entities are keystones to the
multiverse that have the power to
manipulate things like time space and
reality their very existence is what
keeps the multiverse stable some fans
have interpreted that nexus beings
necessarily exist in every universe in
other words if wanda's a nexus being
there must be one of her in every
reality however others believe that
nexus beings exist as single entities
with the ability to do whatever they
want with reality for instance travel
between universes if that's true wanda
should have been able to leap from
multiverse to multiverse already or she
should have been able to manipulate them
without having to dreamwalk it's a
little too convenient that although
she's a nearly all-powerful being with
access to a nearly all-powerful spell
book she needs the specific gift of a
single inexperienced child whom she must
kill to accomplish her ultimate goal
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]